[Music]
on today's show we talk about moving in
together with blended families
we talk about how to love your son when
he's struggling with severe mental
illness
we talked to a young man whose brother
was just in a severe car wreck and the
whole family is trying to figure out
what to do next stay tuned
[Music]
hey what is up this is john with the dr
john dolone show we're so glad you're
here it's a show
for you about you
about your mental health your
relationships whatever's going on in
your life
we'd love to have you on the show give
me a call at 1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-3291
if you want to talk about what's going
on in your life leave a message we'll
call you back have you on the show and i
will do the best i can
to walk alongside you and hey here's the
thing it's free
right so what do you got to lose what do
you got to lose it's not like you have
any investment other than like 15
minutes of your life
i could i don't know there's a lot of
cool things you can do in 15 minutes
that would not
warrant a phone call but hey why not or
if you're not the phone call type
go to johndelony.com ask love
to have you along for the ride james is
still
out so i'm so excited to have ben on the
internets
in there it's good to see you here nikki
b
ruining the cameras today and the
always brilliant kind
inappropriate kelly
like you want something from me disagree
strongly disagree i'd like the show just
to
go on and and so that's what you want
from me
that's what i want from you yes yes yes
so
so glad to have everybody here hey
i often get this question if i don't
watch the news
how do i not live in a hole like where
do i get information from
one of the few places that i've come to
trust
over the past however long is
it's called the marginalrevolution.com
it's
two economists tyler cowan and alex
tabarok
it's i turned it it's a website but i
turned it it's like a blog a running
blog and i turned it into
a an app on my phone that's where i get
my news from
and um these guys are brilliant
statisticians and data minded folks
and i've watched them over the course of
the pandemic the last 18
24 months they have been ahead of
a hundred percent of things it's really
been impressive actually and they love
art
and food and all kinds of good stuff so
it's awesome but
i tell you that to tell you they posted
this yesterday they als also
post a curated list of interesting
articles that come across
planet earth whether it's about chess or
whether it's about
nutrition whatever it happens to be
about they got all kinds of fun stuff
but this this particular this particular
article caught my eye it's and so i've
got on my
my internet phone here my cell phone
which
media have proven uh sticky
as pandemic has diminished and so sticky
is
you know just a nerdy scientific term
for what what behaviors are continuing
on
after the pandemic has begun to recede
and so by a
large margin video games
more than an hour more video games a day
get this a sprawling platform in which
people make and share their own basic
games reported that in the first quarter
of this year
2021 players spent nearly 10
billion hours on the platform nearly
twice as much as they spent on that
same period in a 2020
last year people installed 56.2
billion gaming apps
good folks here's the deal oh whereas
all other generations of americans named
television and film as their favorite
form of home entertainment generation z
ranked them last after video games music
web browsing and social media so
we are seeing a shift number one and i
think the shift is actually pretty good
from passive entertainment just
just absorbing movies and tv to
participation
but 10 billion
hours in the first quarter of video
games just on one platform
let me just make a suggestion go outside
go outside and play with friends right
right little kids out in the lobbies go
play with other people dads play catch
with your kids kick a soccer ball throw
water balloons at each other spray each
other with a hose
plant stuff walk run ride bikes
dig holes catch things set things on
fire
shave your neighbor's head re-roof
something i don't
i whatever you gotta lift weights here's
a crazy thing
jog try that try jogging
or um nerf
guns regular guns everybody's got those
whatever it is 10
billion hours playing a game you could
have
gotten a thou not a thousand a million
at least
phd's in 10 billion hours that's just
the first quarter
the first quarter you can get any number
of
online courses for free local community
college classes
for free cooking classes welding classes
do something besides playing video games
10 billion hours
oh my gosh go outside
and i know it sounds like i'm going
through puberty now my voice is cracking
stop playing video games quit quit
that's all geez louise go outside
go play and i know some parts of the
country right now
it's like a thousand degrees i get that
the one way to make it not so
a thousand degrees go outside i met with
a with a remarkable climate scientist
once
and she said one of the key things you
can do is go outside and your body will
acclimate over time
but it's uncomfortable for a while go
outside even when it's hot
hey here's a crazy thing just serve
other people go paint stuff
pick up trash mow your neighbor's yard
whatever it is
go outside or stay inside read books
read books and i know that's like oh my
gosh read books
write a story write poems you know what
challenge accepted our challenge laid
down
gauntlet consider it uh laid out write a
poem and mail it to me
in an envelope with a stamp and i will
read your poems
online i mean on this show on the
internets
your poem and uh that's what i want i
want poems but they have to be
handwritten
on paper um paper
is this uh product that has lines on it
most of the time it doesn't
have to have lines i don't care it can
be on the back of a newspaper um
but write poems mail them in an envelope
i will not accept him digitally and uh i
will read your poems
on this show that's what we're gonna do
that just solved it
10 billion hours good grief
all right let's go to melody in
knoxville tennessee
melody how are you i'm doing okay
excellent how can i help all right
so um my boyfriend
has asked me to quit my job and move in
with him
um between the two of us
we have five children okay and
this means i will be taking care of his
kids
full-time that concerns me because we
have very
different parenting styles
and i'm wondering what the best way
would be to go about it in such a way
that the tradition the transition is
best
for our kids
oh man so first don't move in
okay you are not ready for that
just listening to your usage of pronouns
and listening to your usage of
you are speaking about this situation as
far arms length as you can get it
okay this other person is asking me to
quit
my job and take care of his kids
you're not there yet okay and i don't
mean this is the end of your
relationship i don't mean that this is
what are we doing why are we it just
means right now you're not there yet
okay do you agree with that or no um
i wouldn't say i agree with that i've
been a uh stay-at-home mom for quite a
while
i'm very comfortable as a stay-at-home
mom and he knows i want to be one again
okay so what is what is yours
okay but you've got a hang up what is it
um well
the only real hang up i have about it
because there's a lot of necessity in
many ways he's helping me out by doing
this because
i'm not in a good living situation and
this is
like very much a lifeline for me so i'm
very happy with that idea and i was
actually very grateful for
the offer okay the only thing is
when it comes to our relationship like
the only real concern that i have
and i'm an exceedingly pessimistic
person especially when it comes to
relationships
just to let you know excellent i i look
at every dude like yeah
yeah you have a curveball what is it you
know absolutely you're gonna throw
something at me
hey real quick just an aside where'd
that come from
uh that mindset yeah i prefer to be safe
than sorry
and well the fact that i'm a single mom
shows that my other relationship didn't
work out too well you've been sorry
before okay
all right so this so you this is a good
thing so what i would tell you is
um i'm not always right
uh-huh but i need you to hear
your language back to you okay okay
somebody you're gonna marry
isn't quote unquote helping you out
someone you're gonna spend the rest of
your life with
invest in their kids co-raise their kids
while they co-raise your kids
that's not to help each other that's not
doing you a solid
that's not you helping out him with
babysitting and him helping out you
getting you out of a job
and you got a crummy living situation
you are setting yourself
up to be um roommates really good
roommates that hook each other up
hey bro you keep take care of my pets
and i'll give you a cut on rent
sweet good deal that's not
saying hey we are going to integrate our
lives together and we're going to create
a new family out of what was previously
two families or three families or
whatever it was
and there's a whole different ethos of
going into this and so
it may be that you're trying to have
both
where you're trying to be safe and
protect yourself and
get into this family and take this thing
for a spin
whatever it happens to be i'm telling
you you're setting yourself up for it
not to work because you're not going all
in
you're going as a business arrangement
or as a roommate partnership and not
as a potential wife
potential combined blended family does
that make sense yeah and i guess i can
i can see very much how you would see it
that way
um i think that's probably how i would
have saw if i was
me two years ago okay so i
understand where you're coming from 100
okay
but that is not how he comes across to
me
um he's been good to me in ways that
my husband of 10 years never ever was
okay and has been going out of his way
to make sure that
like the road is as paved for me as
possible
and you know
he's been giving me the language that
expresses commitment
saying you know i'm going to get married
i want to have
a child with you when we're ready i want
to do you know he's not
being that boyfriend who kind of keeps
you at arm's length says but you could
do stuff for me okay
are you keeping him at arm's length um
no i don't think so okay okay
so whenever this show airs i want you to
go back and listen to just your first
statement
okay but we'll let's let's move on so i
trust you you love him
you're all in on this deal so how can i
help
so my like i said only real concern with
this
is we both have exceedingly different
parenting styles
what does that mean um he
is the um the father of only daughters
i'm the mother of only son okay and
i am exceedingly strict
i have my expectations for my boys my
boys know that they have to
behave this way they have to do these
things everything that you were
describing
earlier about going outside that is me
a hundred percent good for you games are
for
weekend nights only okay but his
daughters will wake up in the morning
grab a soda
and sit down and start playing video
games and he's totally bad
and also you know he
he just i think you know because they
have not really had access to their
mother and he feels a lot of guilt for
that
he's been like really lavishing on them
will buy them things for no apparent
reason
he doesn't expect much of them like
you know my kids are younger than that
than his but they wake up and they know
they have a chore list
they know that they have to finish all
their food they know they have to wash
their plate
they know that i expect them to read
books and you know just all this stuff
whereas his
girl in comparison to my children are
feral i mean
and um so i kind of wonder okay well if
i'm going to be
with the girls full-time and with my
voice
am i supposed to try
to have them disciplined to the point of
that
my boys are working there or am i
supposed to just step back and say you
know these are his girls they're gonna
be raised that way
but if they are raised differently
come to have resentment when they see
that these girls
are spoiled and have no expectations and
they are
free to just do whatever they want and
my sons are being told no you have to do
this you have to
this you can't have that yes but
and if i treat these girls differently
even if they see it as positive like oh
you know she doesn't put these
expectations on us
won't that in their mind make them go
then she doesn't see us as
our her children she doesn't see her
herself as our mother
otherwise she'd be treating us when she
treats her kids
so here's the thing i want to transition
well
yes please you're going to do whatever
you're going to do
but for the sake of those kids all five
of them
don't move in yet okay okay
your relationship is not in a place like
again i want you to go back and listen
to this
the judgment you have over this man that
you love and i do believe that you love
him but you don't like how he parents
you don't think he does it the right way
and you don't think and he probably
thinks you're strict
um you don't like the way that he has
chosen to deal with
the fact that you know his her their
mother isn't there's a lot
here and yes you have nailed it
trying to combine these two families
without some sort of commitment to
we're gonna we're unifying this family
because when you
when you're combining blended families
like let's say you're both getting
married this weekend and you'd call me
we are all in then yes what y'all are
gonna have to do
is really be intentional about what kind
of parents we're gonna be
and that means we're gonna have to set
some really firm boundaries
and it is gonna be world war three
because kids are gonna
bang their head up against those
boundaries to see if they hold
and they especially kids of um
who have gone through divorce they've
lived in chaotic systems
they've been around heartbroken adults
they've tried to prop them up they think
that
to some level this is their fault and
then somebody comes in and says hey no
more cokes no more video games you go
outside you
then you would have to have a season of
understanding that you're going to be
the
considered the worst person on planet
earth
and you're going to have to have your
boyfriend's husband
full backing so that when those girls
run to their
mom or run to their school counselor and
they declare war on you because you're
holding them to this standard
and their bodies get off of sugar and
start sleeping and get off of the bleeps
and the screens
it's you're in for a long transition
and vice versa when you're boys who've
been raised
for the last how long have you been
divorced
um about a year okay
and how long have you all been separated
how about you i
mean it's kind of been well it's it's
complicated my husband
decided that he didn't want to be with
me but didn't want to divorce me so he
moved out but he would come back
whenever he wanted
and he um please please please please
please
paying for he was like paying all my
utilities and stuff and i was just kind
of putting up with it
when he started saying he can see other
women too that's when i said you know
what i'm done i don't want to do this
i've been doing
four listen your boys have got to get
some stability
and they've got to get some sort of
adult stability in their life
and taking those boys from that chaotic
situation
chaos dad's just gone dad just plops
back in
dad's deciding hey i'm gonna have
girlfriends too that relational chaos
between you and him
that manifested itself into the air of
that home
which isn't i get it man the the it's
not to
beat you up over that there of course
there's going to be relational chaos in
that home
if that's the kind of house your husband
was trying to hold together
or that you were trying to hold together
on behalf of that of your husband acting
like a child
and then to take those boys put them
into a house with girls who were being
raised completely different with a guy
you're
not all in on you've been with less than
a year
man you're i'm just telling you you that
it's it's chaos find a new place to live
continue having conversations with your
current boyfriend about hey
what would this look like down the road
not hey
saying all the right things i don't i
don't care about what people say
i care about people how they are right
you all start having conversations about
hey this is how i feel strongly about
not giving kids cokes at nine in the
morning i feel strongly about kids being
outside and playing together
and using their imaginations and not
being on screens and he may say i
feel really strongly about letting kids
just do whatever they want in the
mornings i feel really strongly about
letting kids play video games they're
growing up in a digital world
and they're gonna have to know how to do
this whatever the thing is y'all are
just really far apart
and i get that it would probably be
better financially you're as you said in
a bad housing situation whatever that
means
i get that it would be easier telling
you
the casualty here will be those kids all
five of them
you all aren't ready for it man you're
not ready for that
if y'all were 19 and 20 and you always
can move in together i would tell you
don't but
the stakes would be lower it would just
be y'all you got little kids man they
got to heal from this
you take that whatever you will you're
probably gonna do it anyway and you're
grown up you can do whatever you want to
i'm just gonna tell you to hold off man
hold off melody
and get some healing under your belt
because i'm healing in your
in the house give those boys some some
stability all right
all right let's take a quick break we'll
be right back on dr john delaney show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free guided meditation
it's not really a meditation but really
me just walking with you through your
anxiety alarms from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back let's go to john
in las
cruces new mexico what's up man
hi john how are you outstanding how are
you
i'm good thanks uh the reason i'm
calling is long story short
i'm pretty sure my son is uh bipolar and
schizophrenic
he's an adult i don't there's i can't do
anything for him
you know like i can't ground him i can't
force him to go to counseling or
anything like that
but i sure wish i knew what to do you
know
tell me how did you come to this
realization
well he's been he's been quite the
consumer of cannabis for over a decade
now
and then past weekend or about this past
weekend before last
he was at his mom's he lives with his
mom he's 26.
um was in the backyard uh basically
attacking a shrub with a pair of
whoppers
and for preparing the backyard for an
in-ground pool
and a basketball hoop and
his step-dad went out to try and get the
whoppers
things got physical my son got arrested
and put in jail
went before the judge and the judge can
see he was struggling
and he's been in a psychiatric ward
hospital
for a week now okay um and then
based on a conversation my mom who has a
master's degree in art therapy
had with his mom she said you know now
this is just her opinion she made it
very clear she's not you know the expert
but she thinks that's what's going on
as an example my son told me one time
that his mom and her husband were
sharpening their teeth
with forks at the dinner table um
so there's is it's some pretty out of
control stuff is
i guess the most polite way to put it
sure um
first and foremost man when you love
somebody and they're struggling with
with mental illness when they're
institutionalized i know that blows up
your whole world
and i hate that for you man i've sat
with too many parents in
psych wards and it's it's one of the
more heartbreaking
moments i've spent in my career so i i
hate that for you guys
um i know it's been a tough tough couple
of weeks
when you and him are just hanging out
is he lucid with you can y'all go
fishing can y'all go work on a farm out
there
can y'all i mean can y'all go do stuff
together
well it's it's been a long time since
we've hung out
um how come well i
i i'm in the transportation business
okay i
drive cross-country yep and you know
he's up in a different city with his mom
um and there have been times when i've
gone through his town
and i'm like hey i'm coming through and
you know for well over a year now he
hasn't had a car because it got hit by
lightning and coveted and all that stuff
and
then there were times where he would
just kind of blow me off um or could
make it happen so we haven't had a
quality connect time
for a while now and let me back up about
five years ago
he was smoking spice and
i threw a red flag at that right away i
got hit with oh no no i've done my
research and
you know i'm driving i'm on the fly so
uh okay you know i mean what
like i said a minute ago what am i going
to do ground him you know
and um about a week or two whatever
later
he wound up in a psych ward because he
cooked his brain yeah um
they held him there for three days they
let him go um as i understand he was
supposed to go to counseling he didn't
or he went once then blew it off okay um
so you know are you are you still in
contact with
his mom yes sir
well she only calls me if there's an
emergency okay
so so this is an emergency so here's a
couple of things
um first i don't um
anytime somebody says they got diagnosed
bipolar and schizophrenic
my my
i don't think so goes up my my flag goes
up there
um i don't put a lot of stock
into that dual diagnosis and so
um usually it's some how you just
mentioned it
it's some sort of armchair um
uh somebody that hasn't googled it or
has enough
something like this or a small town i
just don't hear a lot of
people in the literature and hear a lot
of full-time professional diagnostic
giving that comorbid diagnosis okay that
that dual diagnosis
um so what i would do is
um wait till if i'm you i'd get in the
car and go go meet with the doctors
myself
and i would call my my ex-wife or his
mom or whatever
relationship you have to her and y'all
got to come up with some sort of plan
um you're right i smoking weed it
usually
is a um
did y'all have a pretty tumultuous
childhood there
i don't think that he did i mean you
know his mom and i split when he was
four or five okay so yes he did have a
tumultuous childhood
he did you might not feel that he did
but he did um
okay so whatever it looks like as he
ages out and gets older
smoking weed is is doesn't make me lose
my hair
i will throw every red flag i've got on
smoke and spice for that very reason
i've
seen students lose everything over that
deal they just like you
you perfect words it cooks their brain
right and so
i've been there i've seen that um
i would have a circle the wagons game
plan
and ultimately what you're gonna need to
do is get true diagnosis from a true
psychiatrist and sit down with somebody
and say what are we dealing with here
and then come up with some sort of plan
between you and
his mom and him and then you're right he
doesn't get to pro i mean he can choose
not to participate he's 26 years old
and what he's going to end up is either
on the street or he's getting up in some
sort of group home
on government assistance or if it's
schizophrenia he can take medication and
ha and
do counseling and he can have a
productive great life right but it's
finding that right group is going to
connect with him or that right
professional who's going to dial in the
meds
and get some the care that he needs
um usually that takes everybody in his
circle talking the same
language and that means you and
his stepdad and and her getting on the
same page
right right and the problem i'm running
into and his mom is well
he signed paperwork that they can give
her
limited information just generalizations
about
what's going on right um you know what
the doctors are seeing that whole thing
right um he's still in denial about
what happened and why he's there sure
you know like oh you know
he called me the other day and
apologized for his silly mistake
i.e that he grabbed a hold of the ex of
the stepdad
sure you know and so that's
i i'm not i don't know how much
information
i'm gonna get let alone his mom um who
lives in a different city like i said
with him
you know um right that's where
that's where your partnership with a
doctor or
often there is a social worker that
helps run
helps communicate between patients like
this and
parents and families and
community support groups here's what i'm
telling you
i if i'm you i'm on the phone with every
single person i can
i would take off a work if at all
possible or try to route myself through
this community
the way forward is everybody being on
the same page and everybody being
connected
and sometimes having divorced parents in
a room with somebody who's struggling
is a uh what's going on here
and a doctor telling everybody the same
thing and again
he's 26 and it may be a heartbreaking
chest can hardly breathe through my own
tear
situation where he's just gonna not let
anybody have access to anything at any
time
i've just seen persistence and continued
care
and and in person contact do worlds of
wonder
and i've also sat with parents outside
of psychiatric wards or
in my office and that had to explain to
them
i know you're paying for college i know
you're
the psych visit is on your insurance but
your kid is signed away where they will
not talk to you
they think you are part of the problem
amen
there are a few more awkward
conversations but i've had those they're
hard right
that could happen to you what i want
there to be is a
record of me going to the ends of the
earth to try to get the right
information get everybody on the same
page
okay um that may be you reaching out to
her and here's what i say i would tell
you
if your son is diagnosed bipolar
if your son is diagnosed schizophrenia
schizophrenic
there's readings you can do there are
groups you can join there are
you know facebook groups with parents
with kids and
there's all kinds of resources you can
join but you don't even know what this
is yet
or it might be just a bad trip with some
bad
hallucinogens or some bad spice or some
bad k2 whatever it happens to be
and man it may just need to heal his
brain for a little while and then he's
going to be back to normal and then we
got to do the hard work of
why is he a drug addict right so
that's again i think your best friend
right now is information and your best
friend is partnership
even if it's with somebody that you've
struggled being in partnership with
before
and here's the third and final thing
you're gonna have to deal with the grief
of the last five years you're gonna have
to deal with degree for the last seven
years you're gonna have to deal with the
grief
of my son's in a psych ward and i'm
however many miles away
and that means you're gonna have to find
somebody who holds you accountable
to your diet choices to sleeping choices
to not trying to
work your way out of your feelings to go
sit with somebody
and just say hey i'm heartbroken whether
that's a local pastor or a local
counselor there in town
whatever that looks like for you but
you're gonna have to be well and whole
through this deal
otherwise you're going to bring your own
chaos and your own
spin to this situation and it doesn't
need any more chaos doesn't any more
spin to this deal
so in order real quick you need real
information from real professionals who
know what they're talking about
whether that's going to be the
psychiatrists the doctors whomever you
got to get real information not a friend
of a friend not an art therapist who
knows somebody who knows somebody else
you need to get real information okay
real data
number two you and your uh
son's mom have got to agree and step dad
however awkward is for y'all
we're going to come together in
partnership over this deal we're going
to discuss things we're going to learn
from each other we're going to sit in
the same room
and be grown-ups for the benefit of our
son we're gonna figure this thing out
okay and then you're gonna do the best
you can to connect with that hospital
with your son with a social worker with
whoever that is
that can get you back into relationship
with this young man
because through relationship he can be
um i don't say convinced but
through relationship he might decide
okay i'll start taking some medication
through a relationship he might think
okay i don't trust him but i trust you i
don't trust you but i kinda trust her
through relationship that's your only
shot
at him getting some sort of healing him
getting some sort of wellness plan that
he can follow and continue on the rest
of
his days okay and then man
just dad to dad you got to be him you
got to be present man
you got to call him even if you won't
talk to you got to write him letters
even if you didn't write your back
every time you can route through that
that town and if he says yeah i'll meet
you and he doesn't show up
that's on him not you and it will be
heartbreaking it'll be hard
man john that's your son keep showing up
and keep showing up and keep showing up
okay i know it's hard i know it's hard i
know it's heartbreaking every time
keep showing up man thanks for that call
all right let's take one more let's go
to adam in
phoenix hey adam what's up brother hey
dr delaney how are you
i'm good brother what's going on man uh
so the reason i'm calling today is
my 30 year old brother was recently in a
car accident
um and due to the car accident he
is now paralyzed from the waist down no
man sorry i'm so
sorry so so sorry it's heartbreaking man
yeah yeah um so the first four weeks
after the accident
you know he was in the hospital um
having surgeries and
therapies and you know learning how to
live with
what's now it's new life
uh this is a permanent paralysis
the doctors think yes but you know
there's always
hope or right miracles or whatever the
case might be
sure but the prognosis is this is not
temporary this is a a
a new permanent way of being correct
correct
okay yeah so who's he staying with now
so he's actually
living with my parents now because uh he
has a girlfriend but
you know he's not married or anything so
my parents thought it'd be best that he
moves
back in with them okay sorry man i'm so
sorry so how can i help brother what can
i do for you
so since he's come back you know i've
flown out there
shortly after he moved back with my
parents just to visit see how he's doing
you know tried to normalize things a
little bit or help them
or help my parents in any way i could
but since i've left and come back home
since i actually live
in arizona you know just talking with my
parents and
kind of talking with him there's been
you know anger and fights between them
and you know wishes he would have just
died in the car accident
stuff like that so
i guess my question is how can i help
from
so far away um when i'm hearing this
from them um you know i try to talk to
my brother
text him call him you know sometimes he
does respond sometimes
he doesn't and i think it's kind of like
uh
some days are better than others
essentially so
man um so not my brother
but my oldest friend on planet earth um
was in a similar situation the weekend
after he graduated college
um one of his friends ran a stop sign
and he's been wheelchair-bound ever
since
and with some traumatic brain injury and
so
um i remember the arc of
this i think i think he was 19 or 12
he's probably 21.
um yeah it changed everything changed
everything
right a couple of things that i learned
from that situation just
personally is man really what you're
talking about
i took everything personally especially
the first year or two
um i mean i remember visiting my buddy
in the rehab hospital
i mean he didn't know what day it was
didn't know what time it was
yet i took every glance every
dismissal every angry statement that he
would mumble out i took all that stuff
personally man and
i didn't realize the extent of the
trauma inside his body
right i did not ex understand the
extent of grief his mom and dad were
going through
um his little brother is still one of my
best friends in the world
i didn't understand the grief his
brother was going through right i'd
understand the grief i was going through
so the first thing i would tell you is
be real gracious with
everybody there is not a right way to go
through with this
um feeling suicidal after you lost
what feels like everything is isn't is
not out of bounds
i don't say it's normal but it's not
crazy okay
um not knowing what to do not wanting to
talk to people being embarrassed being
ashamed
uh is he able to go to bathroom on his
own or someone have to help him with
that
uh he is able to go to the bathroom on
his own but you know
my parents help you know clean up and
you know after the fact
yeah yeah so all of that is is a level
of discomfort
and embarrassment and shame all that
stuff
and then your parents they they had a
life
right and i know the cool thing is to
say like i'll do anything man i had a
life and i got a 30 year old
um living with me 30 year old who takes
a lot of work and then they're gonna get
cast into who's gonna take care of him
after we're gone
and do we have enough money and we have
to remodel the house
there's all these practical things that
yeah
just come out as anger anger is a normal
part of the grieving process
it's it's wired into us it's okay
so the best thing you can do for them is
and for everybody is one be really great
graceful
right be really gracious number two
keep reaching out man keep reaching out
write letters send funny things
keep reaching out if they call you and
they're angry and frustrated
if you can at any shape form or fashion
put them on facetime so you can see them
they can talk to you
um and just let them talk man just let
them talk it's part of the grieving
process they are heartbroken their whole
worlds have been turned upside down
all y'alls have right um
man and here's where you will get
eventually
if not sooner rather than later i'll
never forget sitting in an ihop
it's me my best friends chris
and caleb who was ryan's little brother
and we had a talk like are we gonna like
we made fun of each other a lot
uncomfortably so um
people would ask like are you all
friends that's just how we talk to each
other we've known each other since we
were zero right
um we talked and we had like man we're
not gonna treat him any different
right if i have to go you know help him
in the bathroom
it's gonna be uncomfortable for both of
us and so we're gonna laugh our way
through this
and or if i'm gonna you know we're gonna
have to get the chair out when we're
going to eat um get a wheelchair out
we're going to eat or going to concerts
but
man we're going to do some fun we're
going to make some fun of each other a
lot and he does it
back really uncomfortable for me man
um and he makes me embarrassed and i
don't get embarrassed for so all i have
to say is this
at some point you're gonna have to
reintroduce
humor brotherly love poking at each
other
bring that back in due time and that
will help
norm this the psychological and
spiritual connections that y'all have
right
he's obviously going to have a different
life because of mobility challenges
one of the hardest things about mobility
challenges is everybody treats you
differently like you're somehow
gentle and broken and there's something
just
compassion about saying nice face
nice shirt that's how you haircut that's
what you're gonna do right
and you suddenly realize oh you're just
one of the guys does that make sense
and so it's not handling him with kid
gloves that may not be the season right
now a few weeks out
right there's still a lot of healing
going on um
but over time you want to be the brother
you were beforehand
right the one that loves him and that
pokes at him and that clowns him about
christmas and
all those fun things that brothers do
and those mean things brothers do
that's going to be a key part of him his
healing and his growth does that make
sense
yep yeah definitely and then here's a
big one man and i did not do this for
years i didn't even know to do it
but you're gonna be grieving from this
too
suddenly things got really mortal right
how old are you
32 32. are you married kids anything
yep married uh one daughter okay
everything in your psychology just
changed
the yeah it could always be worse you
know that kind of nonsense the trivial
stuff that moms you know
sew onto pillows that's real in your
world now
you know what that looks like and it
will
come out and how you parent it will come
out in how
you when your wife is 15 minutes late
calling you
you'll immediately go to those the worst
case scenarios
you'll it'll change what you drive it'll
change the way you interact people
it will change you and so i want to make
sure you
take care of your grief make sure you're
whole man and if that means go to see
somebody go see somebody if that means
you gotta get with a local group
in your hometown get with a local group
in your hometown
if that means being honest and letting
your wife know hey
i'm still struggling with this big time
let her grieve because she's gonna be
grieving too
your wife your daughter and her uncle
right all everybody's gonna be grieving
this thing if you skip the grief part
and try to start solving things man
you're just going to shove it down and
i'm telling you i did that and i didn't
deal with it for
years and i didn't know where all of my
angst and drama and relational issues
were coming from and a lot of it stemmed
back to
oh my gosh man my oldest friend in the
world somebody i loved
dearly just like a brother
one weird turn and it all changed right
so don't dishonor yourself make sure
you're taking care of yourself too
thank you so so much for that call man
thank you so so much for that call
if you're in a season um where you can
sit down and read
again i've recommended this book a
million times um finding meaning
by david kessler it's about grief it's
often about death but this is grief as
grief is grief man there's no
you can't compare it um it's a great
book to
to sit down and read when your parents
are ready to start reading it's a
it's a great book to read as a family
y'all can talk about it you can think
about it but it'll give you some
practical tools
but more importantly it will let you
know you're not crazy
there is no right way to grieve there is
a wrong ways but there's no right way to
do it
continue to show up there for your
family man let him be angry let him be
frustrated let him be heartbroken
if your brother says hey i'm going to
kill myself today obviously called 9-1-1
right but him waking up frustrated and
just beat down by this
is normal man and you too all right
thanks so much for that call
oh it's adam sucks man suck suck suck
sucks brings back a lot of
man all right so as we wrap up today's
show again i was listening to this on
the way to work today man
greatest songs ever written and i think
these guys are the most
common the band i refer to the most on
this show man
um of course off the magpie and the
dandelion record it's the avett brothers
with the really extraordinary song
open-ended life and it goes like this
pack a change of clothes and a pillow
for the road for when we drift off to
sleep
and put the sketches and the notes in a
box labeled burn with furniture
we will watch the fire burn and the
whole entire house will burn down to
ashes
from the mirror we'll admire how the
flame quickly retires
we won't waste no longer goodbyes on the
smoke or foolish lies that finally
passed us
let's find something new to talk about
because i'm tired of talking
about myself i spent my whole life
talking to convince
everyone that i was something else and
the part that kind of hurts is i think
it finally worked
and now i'm leaving and i get the
feeling things have changed but the
mystery to me is where and when along
the way
did anyone decide that they believed me
i was taught to keep an open-ended life
those guys can write this is the dr john
dolone show